-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm here with the one and only
Tariq Trotter
right now, from the Roots.
We're about to play charades,
but first we're going to need
some players here,
so, joining my team,
you can see him
in season 4, volume 2
of "Stranger Things,"
streaming this Friday
on Netflix.
Please welcome Gaten Matarazzo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Talking over each other ]
-Joining Tariq's team, she stars
in the giant summer movie
"Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness."
and her book, "Hattie Harmony:
Worry Detective,"
is available
everywhere books are sold.
Please welcome Elizabeth Olsen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
-Hattie Harmony.
-Hello again.
-Yes. Hi.
-Alright.
So, it's you and Elizabeth.
Me and Gaten.
Okay, now, look, we all know
how to play charades.
We're going to go
four rounds, okay?
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
And then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
Yeah. I will go first.
Everyone can take their seats.
I'll show you how it's done.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Ready?
-Great.
-I'm terrified.
-Who's up first?
You go first?
-Yeah, I can go. Yeah.
-I'm really bad at games.
-Okay, guys, which --
What number should I choose?
-Oh, I'm scared.
[ Audience shouting ]
-"Seven!"
Someone really wanted seven.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Yeah, I can do this. Ready?
-I think so, yeah.
-It's a movie.
It's one word.
Um, what?!
-What'd you say?
-What in the world
is this movie?
Uh...
Ohh, no!
Small. Small.
Short. Tiny.
Tiny. Small. Little.
Ant? Is it an ant?
Oh, man, what did I do?
[ Buzzer ]
-"Minions"!
-"Minions," yes!
I could have gotten that.
-Oh, word?
-It's "Minions"!
[ Laughter ]
-"Minions"!
-How long was that timer?
[ Laughter ]
How long was that timer?
It felt like there was
80 seconds on the clock.
-That was not 30 seconds.
-Jimmy, I'm sorry.
-That felt longer
than 30 seconds.
-Jimmy, I'm sorry.
-What did you say first?
"Once"?
-I said, "What?"
I didn't know what you were --
-You said what?
-Yeah.
-You can't say "what"
in charades!
-Am I not allowed to say --
-"What" is the thing
you don't say! What?!
That's alright.
-I'm so sorry.
-I'll breathe.
-We'll make a comeback.
-We'll get there.
-Elizabeth, you're up.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-We'll get there, Jimmy.
-We're gonna make a comeback.
-In the game. Let's go.
-Do you have a preference?
-Ask the aud--
Three, three, three.
Yep.
-Oh, gosh. Okay.
-They're gonna get it
in 4 seconds.
-It's going to be easier
than "Minions."
-I'm going to start.
-Yep.
It's a song.
-Uh-huh.
-Four words.
Run over -- Run over the hill.
Over the mountain.
Climb over the mountain.
Run up -- up the hill.
"Running Up the Hill."
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got it, we got it,
we got it, we got it.
-Boom.
-Why couldn't have I got that?
-It's understandable.
-Why couldn't I get that
for Gaten?!
I got "Minions"!
-I would have had it in 4 --
-Who said seven?
Who said seven?
You're in trouble,
whoever said seven.
-Who said seven?
-I remember the voice.
I was hearing it
on the street one day.
You walked by and you're like,
"Well, I got seven dollars."
I go, "Seven?! Who said that?"
Okay, Gaten, you're up.
-There was such passion
behind "seven," too.
-Yeah, I know. Yeah.
Alright, well, seven
is already taken care of,
so let's get this.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Good job. Good job.
-Okay.
I'm not listening
to any of you. I'm going --
-There you go. Come on. Whoa!
-Yeah!
-They liked it.
They liked it.
-Oh, great.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I think we got this, bud.
Come on.
-Okay. Alright. I'm going now.
-Yeah, let's do it.
-Okay.
-That's a TV.
-It is a TV show. I spoke.
[ Laughter ]
-TV. It's a movie.
No, it's a TV. Yeah.
"Wonder Years."
Oh. What? Nine words?
Are you joking me?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-"No Good Horrible Bad..."
Three. Three words.
You're doing numbers? Ninety?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Did I --
Did I have a stroke and die?
What -- What happened?
90 Sleeps?
"60 Minutes"?
-It was "90 Day Fiancé."
-Ohh.
-I was getting there.
I was getting there.
-You only have 30 seconds
to "get there."
-You -- You realize
you don't have 90 days?
-[ Laughter ]
-That was a good one.
-Tariq, you give the clues here.
And, Tariq, if you lose this,
you lose points.
-I think we can
make a comeback.
-No, we can do it.
-We lose points if we lose?
-There's a final round.
-This is great.
We got the final round.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Okay.
-He's confident.
-Television show. Two words.
"Breaking Bad."
The Wiggles -- The Wiggles.
The -- The Swiggles?
The Swigg-- Oh, shoot.
The Smurfs.
The -- Oh, my God.
The Squirters.
This -- Guns.
Oh, my God! I'm so sorry!
"Squid Games"!
-Yes!
-Aah!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh. You got that.
"Squid Games."
[ All talking over each other ]
At one point you said
"The Squirfs."
I was like --
That's a new thing. The Squirfs.
Okay. Wow. You guys are good.
-This is really
stressing me out!
-This is a show that --
No, this is fun.
Fun, fun, fun, fun game.
This is the showdown round.
Alright, Elizabeth and Gaten,
you will give clues, okay?
-No.
-Tariq and I will guess.
We got this.
Tariq and I will guess, okay?
We already got the hard ones
out of the way.
"Minions."
-"Minions" and "90 Day Fiancé."
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
Your clues were good.
That was good.
-Okay.
-Yeah, sleeping --
-I was going into "day."
-Now it all makes sense.
It all makes sense, yeah.
You actually even said --
You spelled out "90,"
and I still didn't get it.
Alright.
You guys both give the same
clue at the same time.
Whichever team guesses first
wins 10,000 points
and the whole game.
-Okay. Perfect.
So this is all I need.
This is all we need.
-You got this, Elizabeth.
-Do we have to pick
one of these?
-Yeah. You guys --
You pick the same number.
-Why am I so nervous?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-I get it.
-I'm seeing a lot of ten.
I'm seeing a lot of ten.
Okay, perfect. Great.
-I'm not looking.
Here we go. Come on.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-Alright.
-Got it.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Wait. They both got it.
Hold on a second.
I don't know if I'm ready.
[ Laughter ]
[ Talking over each other ]
-It's weird.
-And...go.
-TV show.
-TV.
"Naked and Afraid."
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-My thanks to Elizabeth Olsen,
Gaten Matarazzo, Tariq Trotter.
-You obviously still lost!
-We're talking to Elizabeth
after the break.
Stick around, everybody. Ohh!